now this isn't a big leap from what
we've been doing
it's just adding a little more
complexity adding a little bit of an
extra step and then we carry on as usual
okay so what can i do here
i picked an example where it's
reasonably straightforward
we've been saying if you can get the
numerator in terms of the denominator
numerator in terms of the denominator
that'll be good because then you can get
things to cancel out
okay now is there anyone who can see
like right off the bat
what might be the most straightforward
way to get the numerator they both have
the same degree right
how can we get this very easily in terms
of the denominator any suggestions
remember my goal is just to cancel out
something right
yeah so up here there's missing a factor
of just
x right just minus so if i add x and
subtract x at the same time you this
uh subtract it there add it there
like so see that okay so now
on the denominator i have this and i'm
in a position to cancel
yes you can see what's going on now
that's okay
but this was an easy example like i said
that's kind of why i picked it out right
so if we had something less obvious over
here
how would you end up with this how would
you get that
this part here now what you're after
really is the division transformation
okay you see why we did it in this order
like polynomials all that kind of thing
how can i see that this where am i going
to get this x plus 1 from
this is really a remainder isn't it it's
a remainder from the division
transformation
so how do we get it if it was a more
complicated example
okay do a long division i'll do it over
here in another color okay
i'm dividing this by this
divide this by this okay so i've got x
squared
minus x plus zero over here
and x squared minus x plus
sorry wait no write the same one again
plus 0x plus 1 here
okay so i'm just going to divide through
it's not going to take very long because
they're the same degree
just so i can get the remainder out and
know exactly what it is okay
because i'm trying to eliminate this
guesswork here some of you saw
reasonably quickly that you add x you
subtract it but others you sort of stand
at it for a little while because it
takes some
it takes some practice to see it right
okay
what's the first thing i do just long
division
how many times is x squared going to x
squared
wow cool all right i know it's early in
the morning but you did it good right
so you multiply down you get this
right now what i'll do with that this is
a lot of inside subtract don't i
so here i'm going to get x
right it's zero minus double negative
and you get one minus zero so you get
one okay ah there's the remainder that i
was after
right because i can't divide this into
this anymore it doesn't go any times
so there's my remainder
okay so what that's telling us is i can
now rewrite it
like this which is actually the next
step
right how many times did it go in it
just went in the once
right so that's this x squared minus x
on x squared minus x that's the one that
hangs out the front
okay and then what's left over is this
okay excellent now what this is better
than what we had before
okay because i've reduced the degree of
this numerator but what does that let me
do now
again partial fractions right so you can
see here it's easy to get out the
factors the linear factors is x and x
minus one
do you need me to do it do you think you
can handle it from there
yeah i think you can do that um